what do you do for a living lay railroad
tracks are you in stomp we're a girl
group ah well your knee has absorbed
years of sustained damage you need a
knee replacement
you can get a second opinion but it will
signal to me that you don't trust a
female doctor
it's tate
don't tell him
hey boy hey where'd you guys go
what we totally said bye you were drunk
bunny well you blew everyone away
tonight so much so that our pr team
wants to start the promo train now
instagram takeovers charity concerts
cooking dog food with rachel ray just
like a million things so that by april
the world will be begging for your album
uh-huh it's gonna be a ton more work but
i know you're all in okay bye god we're
property's horse they're betting on us
larry was right
[ __ ] how long is the recovery for this
it's a major surgery 12 weeks oh 12
weeks
well that's a momentum murderer maybe
tate will understand yeah they have an
april rollout they're not gonna want me
to promote their label post off from a
hannibal lecter board oh hey hoda i know
you booked us to lead a hip-hop yoga
class but what if instead we just teach
america how to drain an incision site i
might watch that what would happen if i
put it off what do you use to prop up
half-dead nfl players steroid injections
painkillers but you'd be in a lot of
pain and your compensation patterns
could lead to damage in your surrounding
joints could lead
not guaranteed though okay but gloria is
this the best thing for you come on
we have all played through pain true
summer did you stop our teen choice duet
with lou baker when you found out your
snake was poisonous no i am profesh
and i definitely didn't let anyone know
when my gallbladder exploded at our
lived vhs christmas
birthdays special christmas
he gets an xbox and hears it for both
[Applause]
[Music]
sure
i can't digest fatty meats now but you
don't cut and run when you have george
wendt playing santa george fricking went
[Music]
girls5eva is back
you